بقعه زيتا عملاقه يخافها اليمنيون فهيكل
سفينه صافر المتاكل شكل منذ عام 2015
قنبله موقوته جنوبيه البحر الاحمر هذه
المخاوف اخفتها قليلا خطه امميه لانقاذ
السفينه تتوزع على اربع مراحل مدتها 18
شهرا وكلفتها تفوق 144 مليون دولار
المرحله الاولى من الخطه ستكملت بالفعل
وتشمل فحص وتقييم الخزان العائم فيما
المرحله الثانيه تتركز على نقل النفط الى
سفينه بديله موقته امنه خزان صافر يعوم
على بعد حوالي ثمانيه كيلو مترات قباله
الصباح اليمنيه ولم يخضع للصيانه منذ
سنوات تم بناؤه عام
1976 كخزان نفط وتحول عام 87 الى وحده
عائمه للتخزين في الوحده احاديه الهيكل
بطولي 362 مترا تحوي نحو مليون ومئه الف
برميل من الخام الخفيف خبراء حذروا من
مغبه التاخير في عمليه تفريغ النفط خشيه
حدوث تسريب او انفجار للسفينه نتيجه
تتراكم غازات الانفجار المتطايره او
الاصطدام بلغم بحري عائم ما سيؤثر على
حياه 12 مليون شخص وبيئه بحريه فريده
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات